with an inflation rate that is nearing
10 percent all eyes were on the federal
reserve and the announcement of its plan
to try to push it down
against this backdrop today the fomc
raised its policy interest rate by
three-quarters of a percentage point
and anticipates that ongoing increases
in the target range for the federal
funds rate will be appropriate
the increase was not unexpected and the
stock markets which have been calling
for aggressive fed action rose sharply
on the news
bolstered also by the fed chairman's
contention that the country was not in a
recession it doesn't seem that the us
economy is in recession right now
that along with the fact that he left
the door open about the size of any rate
move in september as the stance of
monetary policy tightens further it
likely will become appropriate to slow
the pace of increases while we assess
how our cumulative policy adjustments
are affecting the economy and inflation
the rate increase is going to directly
affect this dc smokehouse its owner mel
heinz plans for expansion had already
been impacted by rising inflation
obtaining wood obtaining cement really
went through price adjustments uh so we
were
my contractor was conscious of it
but of course you know it rolls down the
hill so it has to come to me as well so
you know you make adjustments to the
project plans you make adjustments to
how you operate
and so the price increases are passed on
to the customer who's now expecting a
better product for the higher price i
mean we check prices i mean if we walked
out of here you know satisfied with the
food we ate we don't care about prices
but you know if we're not satisfied with
the food
economists maintain the rate hike was
the only tool the fed has to counter
inflation in the long term
but in the short term the medicine is
going to have a bitter taste
mike hannah al jazeera washington